les collectivités territoriales ne sont
pas un problème mais une chance pour la
france est depuis plusieurs mois un
groupe de sénateurs planchent sur la
réforme constitutionnelle
un chantier d'envergure lancée par
emmanuel macron en juillet dernier
devant le congrès à versailles
entre le président français et le
président du sénat gérard larcher les
avis divergent sur plusieurs points
l'interdiction du cumul des mandats dans
le temps ou encore la réduction du
nombre de parlementaires
nous proposons de préserver l'ancrage
territorial des parlementaires en
prévoyant à l'article 24 de la
constitution l'élection au mois d' un
député un sénateur par département vient
s'ajouter la question du cumul des
mandats dans le temps des élus locaux et
des parlementaires qui ne paraît pas
acceptable en l'état
pour une majorité du groupe du travail
pour le sénateur des yvelines et chef de
la chambre haute du parlement il faut
avant tout préserver le lien entre les
parlementaires et nos territoires
je vais prendre un exemple montigny le
bretonneux avant-hier près de 1000
personnes
comment voulez vous que l'on dise temps
si la relation entre un parlementaire
des maires et les citoyens autre projet
qui tient à coeur gérard larcher la
ligne 18 du grand paris express sont à
venir devraient être précisées dans les
prochains jours il n'y a pas de vrai
avenir solide pour le plateau de saclay
et donc aussi de versailles à
rambouillet pour toute cette partie là
si nous n'avons pas des moyens de
transport concernant le projet de loi de
révision de la constitution il devrait
être présenté fin février par le
gouvernement